[Music]
i'm gregory hirsch well i'm not gregory
now i'm my human name is
nicholas braun and i play gregory hirsch
in succession and my human name is
matthew mcfadyen my make-believe human
name is tom warmscans and we're about to
play a game called who said it i'm not
going to put a voice on it or anything
no just do it straight straight just the
words and then yeah and i'm terrible at
things like this anyway it's time
to play the game
and let us begin let's begin he made me
a [ __ ] offer and i'm going to redeem
that coupon i think it's shiv
you're right
i won't give up
i won't
he made me a [ __ ] offer and i'm gonna
redeem that coupon
season two episode eight said to you re
logan's offered to have her take over
yeah that's why i remembered it because
it was yeah it was said to you recently
i memorize all your scenes
even if i'm not in them i watch the
dailies are you involved in the editing
of the show yes weirdly all your scenes
yeah okay they let me pop in there and
yeah chop chop chop chop chop did they
ask you if you wanted to be involved or
did you they actually asked me if i
wanted to direct your scenes
yeah then i'm not really yeah
okay on we go
come on nick do you well
go on
give it your best shot
sometimes it is a big dick competition
logan yes yes good scene great scene
okay who says this i didn't want you to
find out this way tom but i'm in a
sexual relationship with your mother oh
that's uh roman wrong it's jerry
it's tough to have to tell you like this
but i'm in a sexual relationship with
your mother
she talks in her sleep that's a very
sharp jerry line it is she's sort of
putting me back in my box because i'm
threatening to have a press conference
about the cruise line stuff tom
yes sit on the floor
it's fun
seriously yeah it's a game boar on the
floor i really i feel get down
i want to see you piggy fox eat oh
that's logan in boron's floor it's roman
i'm born what yeah
joining in like daddy the next one is
the logan roy school of journalism
what's next the jack the ripper women's
health clinic i think it's jerry i think
it's carl name a few more characters i
think it's roman actually [ __ ]
who's my grandpa james cromwell logan
roy school of journalism what's next the
jack the ripper women's health clinic
here comes the next one at you welcome
to our city on the water it's like
venice but it smells nice
uh let's see if i can do an impression
welcome to our no that's not good
that's not good welcome to our city on
the water it's like venice
but it smells nice very much looks
delicious connor i was trying to do
connor okay
go hard go fast you lovely bastards
what could that be about oh oh
roman yes soccer team yes perfect
go hard
go fast go you lovely bastards
go your lovely bastard what the [ __ ] am
i supposed to say i have no idea
i don't know how
dug that out nick won i think it was
fair
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you
we'll [ __ ] beast them
we'll go full
[ __ ] beast
[Music]
you